good morning everyone
and um thanks for coming to my talk i'm
professor david wood at ohio state
university
and for about the last 20 years i've
been working on a technology involving
self-cleaving affinity tags
i'm in a position now where we've
co-founded a company and are hoping to
commercialize this technology in the
next couple or three months
and i wanted to tell you a little bit
about where it came from what it can do
and where i think it's going
and so what i wanted to do was just to
get us all on the same page
do a very very quick introduction into
biopharmaceuticals because this is
really where we see this tag making a
big difference
and so as you know biopharmaceuticals
are very large drugs they're
polypeptides
much larger than conventional synthetic
molecules
and as a result they need to be
expressed in some kind of a living host
cell
bacterial expression e coli and
mammalian expression of heck and cho
are probably the two most common ones
but there's yeast and insect
systems as well so as a consequence of
these
complex molecules being made in complex
cells there's quite a lot of impurities
that have to be removed
before these drugs can be injected into
a human patient
and really where our technology has its
impact is in this purification this
downstream processing
of the of the purification of the
proteins and of course the main thing
that we worry about
is host cell proteins and getting rid of
those but
really getting rid of all of these and
getting the drug in a way that it can be
injected into a human
and so a consequence of the
biopharmaceutical industry
the the large profit margins for these
drugs
has led to a couple of important points
that kind of dominate the thinking of
the industry
and one is that the speed to market is
absolutely critical
the way i explain it to my students is
if you have a drug that's going to make
a billion dollars a year
that translates to roughly three million
dollars a day
so for every week that that that drug is
delayed
um it's costing basically the salaries
of everybody who's ever worked on that
drug
and so the speed to market is really
critical
and part of what comes out of that is
that the industries become very
conservative so if there's any risk
associated with the drug
they really don't want to take a lot of
risks and they like to keep their own
platforms there is some pressure to
innovate and as things change that
pressure is becoming
greater but right now the industry would
like to stick to the technologies that
they know and that they know that they
can get past the fda
and those two things coming together
create the third point which is that a
lot of these drugs are made using
established platforms especially for
monoclonal antibodies
so if you have a different drugs they're
all basically made the same ways
and some of the things that are changing
now is that the cost of goods are
starting to become important especially
as biosimilars are being released
and there's a lot of new modalities on
the horizon with things like gene
therapies
and exosome delivery vehicles and new
types of
antibodies and antibody fragments but if
we go back and kind of look at this sort
of big established platform
um what we start with is a bioreactor
that has our cells whether they're e
coli or mammalian
uh this system that i'm showing you is a
perfusion system but one way or another
that
that cell brought gets clarified
and put onto a series of chromatography
columns the first one is usually
referred to as the primary capture
and so these chromatography columns when
i'm explaining this to investors and
and other people who don't know much
about bioprocessing they're like brita
water filters where you
put a liquid through the liquid has a
whole bunch of stuff in it like a
vegetable soup and if you're lucky
your brita water filter will grab on to
just what you want
which would be either your drug or
everything that's not your drug
and that allows you to sort of allow a
purification of the drug pretty easily
and so i know given the audience you
already know all of this stuff but
um i've gotten into the habit of kind of
explaining where my thoughts are on
downstream processing
going forward and so if we go back to
the monoclonal antibody platform
this is the one that makes about 70
percent of the revenues in the
biopharmaceutical industry come from
monoclonal antibodies
even though if you look at the number of
therapeutics they only represent about a
third of them
so they tend to be very lucrative and
what's uh
the reason that there's a single
platform for all these monoclonals
humira
ambrol rituxan these things that you see
on tv
is that they all have basically the same
structure so what gives them
their identity is what we call the
variable domains
at the end so those are going to vary
depending on what drug you have
but on the other end of the monoclonal
there's what they call
the constant domain and the constant
domains are all bound by protein a
which is this first affinity column that
allows you to purify
all of these different antibodies at 95
purity
so the point that i'm making is that
these antibodies because they have
a single feature that is common to all
of them a single platform can be used to
purify
pretty much all of them and then there's
some polishing steps but once you're at
greater than 95
purity the polishing steps are not too
hard to to create
and so if you look at protein a because
it's so effective it's the current
platform
and what a lot of people complain about
is that the protein a resin costs quite
a lot twelve thousand to fifteen
thousand dollars per liter
and at full scale you have a a column
that's two meters in diameter and half a
meter deep
holding 1500 liters and so the resin
is about 20 million dollars to do uh a
single process
and so a lot of people talk about how
expensive that is and how it's a huge
problem but it
but there is a lot of thinking that goes
into this uh the resin can typically
bind about 50 grams per liter
and it can be regenerated a whole bunch
of times upwards of 200 plus
times so over its lifetime that one
liter will purify about 10 kilograms of
mab
so the protein a resin once you equal
that all out and
account for its reusability it
represents only about a dollar and a
half per gram of maverick
uh produced out of about a 300 to 100
total cost
and a typical mab remember sells for
2000 to eight thousand dollars per gram
so the protein a resin as expensive as
it seems
is really a rounding error on a rounding
error um in terms of the cost of the
protein and as a result this is a great
example to follow
of a really well-established platform
that's used by pretty much every company
that makes monoclonals
and when we first started our
self-cleaving technology
people asked if it could be used with
maps but what i realized over time is
that
only the worst kind of fool tries to go
up against protein a although i will
tell you i've seen some very exciting
talks about continuous precipitation
so the the challenge that we had was not
how to be protein a we're not even going
to try to do that
what we decided is let's look at these
two thirds of all other therapeutic
proteins
that also have to be purified by some
other platform
now the problem with these proteins is
they don't have any common features
those proteins that i'm showing you on
the bottom half of the slide they're all
actual therapeutics tissue plasminogen
activator is in there
you can see little insulin over there
sort of on the left and then there's
neupogen and epogen and other other
drugs
in that group but they all they're
proteins but they all look different so
the question is how do you purify them
and in a conventional process what you
do is you think
you assume that you're going to have to
do conventional chromatography
and you could assume by starting that
you're going to do a three column
process
and so let's say that you for the first
column that you're going to look at for
the first column in the process
you're going to look at an anion
exchange column now for that single
column you're going to have to
optimize the column type whether it's q
or d-e-a-e which vendor
you're going to have to look at the ph
and the conductivity you're going to
have to look at residence time different
volumes wash volumes
and you're going to have to look at
regeneration protocols and each one of
these parameters is going to require a
combinatorial set of experiments
there's very clever ways to do it with
design of experiments you can have
robots do a whole bunch of experiments
but at the end of the day you're you're
going to end up doing this for every
single column in this three column
process
and each protein is going to require a
certain column
in a certain order where each column is
optimized for that product
and at the end of all of this it can
take six months or longer to develop a
commercial scale process
if you don't have any kind of a common
feature so you have to start from
scratch with each new protein
and this leads to some real real
problems with developing these drugs it
slows it down
it creates risk which the industry hates
and so the question is can we come up
with
a platform for everything else a single
affinity capture that would be able to
purify all these proteins
and of course those of you who work in
the area of protein expression
especially at high throughput research
and laboratory scale
you say well of course there is we'll
just put on an affinity tag
and so the affinity tags you're cloning
the dna of the target protein into
whatever cell you want to make that
protein in
but then you add a little piece of dna
to it that creates a tag so that when
that protein gets expressed it has this
little wrench
ready to grab onto something and you can
go ahead and put tags on pretty much
anything
so i'm just kind of flipping through put
a tag on all these proteins
and now when you're done all of these
proteins now have a common feature they
all have a tag on it
and therefore they can all be purified
using a single
uh affinity resin that that tag will
grab onto
and so most of you have used the his tag
some of you might have used the maltose
binding tag or gst
many tags available many systems the
twin strap tag i could go on and on
and this allows you by tagging a protein
to purify really any protein you want
using a single column using a known
uh unknown protocol so for high
throughput this is really necessary
because you don't have six months for
every new protein that comes down the
pipe
but if you're in the biopharmaceutical
industry typically your target protein
is a human protein like
insulin or growth hormone or something
like that or a human antibody
and the idea is that if you use a human
protein you don't have to worry about an
immune response like back in the day
when people would use cow or pig
insulin and about a third of the
patients would become allergic to it
the problem is the tag the tag is not
human
which means it is potentially
immunogenic
so if you were going to try to use a tag
based method to make a protein that you
wanted to later inject into a patient
you would have to remove that tag and so
the conventional way to remove the tag
is to add a protease and hopefully it
will target
a protease recognition sequence that you
put between the tag and the protein
and then you have to do another process
to get rid of the cleave tag and get rid
of the protease although there's been a
lot of progress on putting his tags on
the protease to get it
uh to be able to subtract it pretty
easily but at the end of that you end up
with your purified product so you might
say well
well the problem solved then we're just
going to put tags on everything and and
do that for clinical research
but here's the problem uh the first is
that when you go to scale this up the
protease enzymes are actually quite
expensive
they have to be produced at gmp quality
in order to be introduced
to your gmp quality process you still
have to do the additional processing
but what's even more of a headache
especially in high throughput research
is that sometimes these proteases
randomly chop up your product protein
and then every other times you add the
protease and it just doesn't cleave off
the tag
and you don't know why and people talk
about stereo kindreds and other things
but it becomes something that even
though it works great and people do it
at laboratory scale
uh proteolytic cleavage especially with
an endopeptide like this
is never used in bioprocessing ever you
will not find a drug where there's a
protease removal of a tag
i heard a rumor once that there's one
where they use an exopeptidase to get
rid of a his tag but i was never able to
identify
which protein that was so even though
some of you may know something that i
don't
i think all of us would agree that this
isn't extraordinarily uncommon in
manufacturing
so there's your problem you need to use
an affinity tag at research scale where
you don't have six months to look at
each new target
but at manufacturing scale you don't you
can't have an affinity tag so what often
happens in companies is they say okay
i'm just gonna leave the tag on and i'm
gonna do all of my pre-clinical studies
with the tags so i'm going to do my
binding studies
my assay my talk studies but deep down i
know
that if i go into clinical trials with
that tag protein
i'm going to get blocked the fda is
going to have a fit and they're going to
say you got to get rid of that tag
before you start having patients with
immune responses
and the upshot of all of this is that if
you
are going from discovery to clinical
manufacturing
in discovery you're going to have
tag-based systems you don't really have
a choice because you have too many
proteins coming down the pipeline
and not enough time to figure out a
formal process for purifying them
on the other hand when you go into
clinical manufacturing you're going to
have to
come up with a complicated new process
that's going to take months to develop
and at some point between discovery and
manufacturing you're going to have to
make that transition
and so this slide was made by my student
joe terrace who's graduating soon
and has done quite a lot of the work
that i'm going to be showing you today
um but i have a little picture of him
because i blatantly stole this slide
from him and i figured i should
uh keep his photo on it at least but
i'll talk about him at the very end
so that really comes into where my talk
is so the idea is can we
engineer a new universal purification
platform but that will create a tagless
target
and is therefore useful at research
skills for high throughput applications
where you need to look at a lot of
different proteins in a hurry
but then can go seamlessly into
manufacturing and deliver a protein that
the fda would consider safe
and so the story begins with the
discovery of this kind of protein
elements called an
intene that's a self-splicing protein so
those of you who do a lot of molecular
biology remember self-splicing introns
and in team splices at the protein level
and forgive me if you've already heard a
lot about in teens
when i was starting my phd in teens had
just been discovered
i started my phd in 1993 and for the
first 10 or 15 years of my career
i spent a lot of time explaining to
audiences even in biology conferences
what in teams were
and somewhere along the way it seems
that they've gotten into textbooks and
now even the undergrads in my classes
know what they are and they sort of roll
their eyes when i explain them again but
some
habits are hard to break but in any case
the intent can self-splice and what's
cool about the intent is you can move it
to a different context and it will still
function it's completely self-contained
at least many in teams and so pretty
quickly
the splicing mechanism was figured out
and i'm not going to go into detail on
that
but an upshot of that understanding of
the splicing mechanism was the
generation of intunes that rather than
splicing the two x deans together
could either cleave the ecstine from one
terminus or cleave the extine from
another terminus
and so the n-terminal cleaving is
generally induced by thiol addition
and it's a chemical cleavage of a
thioester that forms during the first
step of the splicing and then the
splicing is arrested
so the thiol effectively cleaves the
thioester bond
the c terminal cleaving on the other
hand is induced by a temperature ph
change so it's spontaneous but is
sensitive
at least a little bit to the
environmental conditions
and so as a phd student i'd been working
at amgen for a couple years making
neupogen
and i knew that adding 50 millimolar
thial to anything is not going to be
scalable
so i decided to focus all of my efforts
on c terminal cleaving and we came up
with the big idea
and the big idea was that we'd still
have our affinity tag our binding domain
but
now we'd add an intent between the
affinity tag and the product protein
we could express that as a tripartite
fusion protein
and then go ahead bind wash but instead
of eluding and then using a protease to
cleave off the tag what we would do is
we would simply trigger
the tag to self-cleave by the ending
mechanism
and release the product now tagless from
the bottom of the column
and this was very cool and in my phd
work we
started with our mycobacterium
tuberculosis in teen
this is not a picture of it but it's a
picture of one that looks just like it
we deleted the homing endonuclease
domain to create a minion team to make
the system more efficient
we went ahead and did some directed
evolution using a genetic selection
based on thimodillate synthase
and that genetic selection allowed us to
find a cleavage mutation
and this figure is from our first my
first first author paper that ended up
in nature biotechnology which was pretty
nice
and what the cleavage mutation does is
it allows
the ph sensitivity of the cleaving rate
to become
greatly accentuated so what you see is
the rate constant in the y-axis
the ph and the x-axis and as you go from
ph 8 to about six
one of these in teens suddenly cleaves
much much faster
and that inseam became known as delta
icm
and so delta icm it turns out is also
sensitive to temperature and ph and so
it gives you a lot of levers to pull if
you're going to try to control this
the cleaving activity and so the big
idea was that you could
express the protein at relatively low
temperature in e coli where the
intracellular ph is about seven and a
half
you get an uncleave precursor protein
which then you could stabilize by lysing
the cells at ph 8.5
do your binding and washing at ph 8.5
and then shift the ph
induce cleaving and get your clarified
your purified product out the bottom of
the column
in a single step where really all you've
had to do is change the ph
which is quite trivial compared to
adding a protease
and so pretty quickly we went ahead and
published this in teen and here's a
protein gel
in lames one and two it's the whole cell
lysate in the clarified lysate
of a maltose with an in ten and the
target protein in this case is human
acidic fibroblast growth factor
uh we induce the cleaving reaction in
this case by putting a ph front slowly
through the column and allowing the
protein to cleave and collect as a peak
and then at the end of the process we
just add maltose buffer and we can
regenerate the tag
strip off the tag regenerate the resin
and what you see is that the precursor
protein is almost completely depleted
and all you see really left on the
column is cleave tag
but this this gel shows sort of really
high purity that you can get from a
single
uh in ten resin and we had under loaded
the column i will admit
because maltose tags tends to leech off
a lot
but here's another example where we
purified a subunit of rna polymerase and
again
in this in this gel we have the time
course so in about two and a half hours
we were able to collect a very highly
purified product peak
again with maltospining protein as the
tag and our delta cm antene
in this case we raised the column
temperature to 30 degrees to accelerate
the cleaving reaction but in two and a
half hours we could collect a fairly
nice
concentrated and a highly purified peak
from a single column
so we were very excited we published a
bunch of papers
and of course we filed a patent and the
patent issued several years ago
i think 2005. and
um and we you know
we were off to the races we were all
going to become millionaires
we found companies that were excited
about this and it was going to be great
now what we didn't know or we sort of
knew is that new england biolabs was
also developing their own
uh intent-based technology that in this
case was induced by file edition
and it became known as the impact system
um
and they were able to get this system to
work
and they also publish papers and i have
to admit that a lot of the early
really breakthrough work uh on the ante
mechanism was done in new england bio
labs
along with a few academic labs so they
really added a lot to the field
but unfortunately they also decided to
file some patents
and if you've heard of the impact system
and you've never heard of delta icm
the reason is because they got to the
patent office before us
and so if you've used any intent
technology you probably
remember this figure from the brochure
and you've used the impact system
so i could give a whole other talk about
how we were unable to
come up with a reasonable license
agreement with them
but in the end they effectively blocked
us from commercializing our technology
and in return we didn't allow them to
use our technology
so the impact system and eventually the
p twin system was sort of what you got
even though to this day i will still
argue that our technology is probably
better
so that's how things stood as i was
graduating from high school
or not high school from my graduate work
but there was still a problem that
nobody wanted to talk about because we
didn't know how to solve it
and the problem was that even though we
had this great intent that had a really
nice ph sensitivity
so the rate constant on the left here is
actually log units so you're talking
about a huge difference in cleavage rate
over ph and temperature
and in e coli it turns out the cleavage
was pretty slow it had a half hour seven
of a half life of 17 hours and of course
you express proteins in e coli for a few
hours so if you have the right protein
and you express it at the right
temperature
typically you can get precursor and you
can purify it and you can get the
cleavage reaction and everything's
awesome
but i have to tell you if i had a nickel
for every time somebody said is this
going to work in cho i wouldn't have to
write any grant proposals
and so the problem with cho is that
under the conditions of expression where
the growth media is ph seven and the
temperature is really close to 37
the intent wants to cleave much faster
and its half-life is about one and a
half hours instead of 17 hours and of
course if you've ever done any kind of
mammalian expression you know
that the expression takes several days
if not weeks
and so the result is that the tag has
completely cleaved off of the target
protein before you ever get it out of
the cell culture reactor
so you'll do a great job of purifying
the tag but your protein is going to
float away with all the contaminants
because it's not going to be attached to
the tag
so there we stood basic intense designs
impact xeon on the left
which we knew required file that would
destroy disulfide bonds
was too expensive and too toxic to
really scale up
on the other hand we had the ph and
temperature shift of our antene
but that led to a lot of premature
cleavage and of course the thing that
all of us didn't want to talk about and
and just swept under the rug was that it
had both of them showed unpredictable
cleavage behavior
so sometimes with lti cm your target
protein would cleave completely
no matter what you tried to do other
times it would cleave very slowly or not
at all and the same was true for impact
cn
and so this is sort of where we left it
i
graduated with my phd i went to work at
princeton
and for the next 20 years i kind of
played around with trying to make this
a more attractive system and so one of
the things that we published was elp
tags what elp tags do is it's a long
polypeptide tag that you can add just
like an affinity tag
but if you add a little ammonium sulfate
or raise the temperature they fall out
of solution and become insoluble
in a very reversible way so you take an
elp you put an intent you attach it to a
target
and you can do a pretty decent
purification if you look at lane six
we're purifying chloramphenicol acetyl
transferase
basically in a single test tube by just
precipitating washing resuspending
cleaving and then precipitating the tag
and so this was pretty cool we got that
into nature methods
we showed that you can actually get
pretty high purity
if you wash the pellet a couple times
and and kind of optimize it
we showed that you can attach the elp
tag to one subunit of a larger
complex in this case it's the e coli rna
polymerase
and by just tagging one subunit you can
actually purify all of the other
subunits
um it looks like there there might have
been some disappearing but the beta beta
prime
alpha sigma and omega all purified this
way
and of course we showed that you could
use it for high throughput purification
and there was a lot of interest in this
a lot of labs
requested it and another thing that we
went ahead and looked at is i wanted to
try to figure out how to get this into
the biopharmaceutical industry
and so i worked with a guy jesus sans in
spain
who had developed something called the
lie tag and what the lie tag was is it's
a
a choline binding domain from
streptococcus
but it turns out choline looks a lot
like a coronary amine and so i thought
well if it'll bind to choline why won't
it bind to a cuceferous column that i
can get
that's ready for a gmp process and sure
enough
if we if we put this lye tag this
choline binding domain with an intene
we can get really nice purity using a
dea
column where the protein binds as if it
were an affinity column so extremely
precise you can raise the salt to
something really really high
knock everything else off and then
cleave the target and leave the tag most
of the tag
on the column and again we hugely
overloaded this column to give you an
idea of what kind of purity you could
get
and the beauty is this was a you know
would be a dea resin that you could buy
from
ge or i guess now sativa and go ahead
and put straight into a gmp process
so ironically we never published that
it's still sitting in an inbox everybody
graduated
but we had all these great ideas for how
we were going to come up with ways to
try to
get this this antene into the
biopharmaceutical industry and hopefully
turn it into a platform
and so 20 years later this is where i am
and i'm going to tell you what we've
been doing now the problem is 20 years
later
even though i played a lot with tags and
i played a lot with sort of trying to
figure out how to make the intent work
in biopharmaceutical
applications at the end of the day we
never really solve these problems
where we either have a thioline team
that destroys disulfide bonds
or we have this premature cleaving that
keeps you out of mammalian cells
and so what ended up happening was we
got included on a darpa project where
the goal was to create
a briefcase that could make any
biopharmaceutical in 24 hours
so this would be something that you
would carry around with you
um and it was for soldiers on the
battlefield and if you needed a dose of
insulin you would just type in insulin
growth hormone type in growth hormone
humira type in camera
and out in 24 hours later would pop a
single dose ready to inject of whatever
drug you had asked for
and as you can imagine if we would have
to be able to purify these proteins
and so i was approached because people
saw my ante technology and they said hey
if you can really purify anything with
these in teens
then we want to use this technology in
our darpa briefcase to make all of these
drugs
and it's a very exciting technology the
lead on the project was a guy named
govind rao
at university of maryland at baltimore
county and he is still pushing that
technology i'm not going to talk about
it very much today but if you
email govind or google govan rao or the
darpa biomod
project biomod you'll you'll get to
learn all about it and some papers were
published and it
was pretty cool but at the end of the
day
these problems the ph temperature shift
was still a headache for us because even
in the biomod system we were still
getting premature cleaving before we
could do the purification
and so at that time i had a visiting
student from china named chang hua shi
he goes by stephen and he's at wuxi now
he's interested in returning to the
united states and i should tell you if
you can catch him
he's an incredible uh incredible
scientists
um and he told me that you know people
were looking at these split-ending
systems
and there were naturally occurring split
in teams that were pretty soluble
and behaved pretty well but the beauty
is they can't cleave until they assemble
so these are intunes that are expressed
in their native host in two segments
from separate genes they float around
inside the cell until they find each
other and then they go ahead and they
splice
and so the idea was that we could
assemble these on the column
wash the column and cleave and we could
get rid of the premature cleaving
and so in order for this to work we
would need things like ph sensitivity
rapid cleaving reliable performance we
need all the things that you want from a
protein purification system
and we set about to re-engineer the npu
split in team
so we started with our basic idea where
we just put a split into where the
existing end team was
the first thing that we did and we were
following the lead of a of a scientist
at texas a
m named shyly chen we moved the affinity
tag to the other end
of the n-intene and this sort of tricked
the intent into thinking that the first
step of the splicing reaction had
already taken place
and that releases the third step of the
splicing reaction and greatly
accelerates it
the second thing we did is we made the
same mutation that we have in our delta
icm
inten which also accelerated the
reaction we neutralized a couple of
cysteine residues and i'll explain why
in a minute
and we've made a steering to histidine
that would also help uh
accelerate and make it ph sensitive so
basically we're taking our entire
knowledge base
and applying it to this intune in a very
rational way because it turns out for
split in teams
directed evolution is hard and what we
found was this
intense so here's the precursor protein
at hour zero and at hour 16 you can see
that it's cleaved
at ph 8.5 you get a little bit more than
50 percent cleaving
at 16 hours but at ph 6.2 you get a
little bit less than that
so it's a little bit ph sensitive but
the truth is nobody's going to want to
wait 16 hours at room temperature
to have their in team work so what we
did was and this is again a really long
story we started looking at the residues
at the front end of the antene
and so we took that minus one the first
residue before the antene
outside of the antene and we changed it
to all
20 of the naturally occurring amino
acids and then we measured the rate
constants at ph 6.2 and 8.5
and what you realize is the identity of
that amino acid has a huge influence on
how fast it cleaves
on the other end but also has a huge
influence
on the ph sensitivity and so we did some
rational engineering and some mutant
design and we set up a fret system
that allowed us to track cleaving and we
did some high throughput screening
and we eventually settled on gdghg
immediately preceding the inseam and we
call this
the sensitivity enhancing domain
and along the way if if you look at that
previous slide we came up with a bunch
of different combinations of amino acids
that give us really
almost a continuum of different
behaviors for the antenna cleavage
reaction
and we haven't even started mining that
for what we might be able to do with
those
but the sensitivity enhancing domain we
put on the front end of the antene
and now if you look at ph 8.5 in 16
hours you see
uh maybe 20 or 30 percent cleave but
remember you're going to be doing your
your binding and washing at 8.5 you're
probably going to have everything done
within an hour or two
where you see very very little cleaving
meanwhile at ph 6.2
you have about 90 cleaving in five hours
and so this is the target that we were
looking at of getting a really
ph controlled in teen cleavage where we
would eliminate all premature cleaving
but still have that good handle during
the purification
process and so what we did is we took
that intent we added a his tag to the
front of it
we added a now unique cysteine residue
because we'd neutralize the other
cysteine residues
and then we would use that file on the
cysteine residue to covalently bind it
to an affinity resin
and the idea is you would buy this
affinity resin from us and we call it
the icap tag resin for intene capture
tag
and we would sell you this just like you
would buy a protein a resin or any other
affinity resin and then you as the
customer would take the 35 amino acid
um c terminal in team segment and you
would put it on the front end of
whatever target protein you were trying
to purify
and you would put it into whatever cell
host you you liked
and the idea was that you would then
bind that to our resin
it would become ph sensitive so you'd
bind at ph 8.5 you'd shift to 6.2
and your protein would cleave ideally
within five hours at room temperature
but i'm going to get to how you can
tweak that a little bit as well
and so the first thing that we decided
to purify besides the green fluorescent
protein which was a lot of our
our development work was uh granulocyte
colony stimulate
stimulating factors so this is
filgrastim which is the generic name of
the drug nupogen
which ironically is the drug that i used
to work on when i worked at amgen so i
know the protein really well
and i knew a lot about the conventional
methods for expressing it and
um refolding it and purifying it
and so you see the binding phase where
all of the proteins come through the ph
8.5 buffer to wash out all of the
contaminants
ph 6.2 and then we stop the column
incubate for 20 hours and i'll get back
to that and then we
loot this the product the cleave product
and here's the result so the purified
gcsf that you see on the left again
a single column process this is a high
sensitivity silver stain gel
it's a little bit overexposed even but
you can see the clarified lysate and the
flow through
and you can see the purified gcsf in the
elution bands in the middle and then we
had a non-reducing gel
as well but i would argue this is really
kind of a nice purification for a single
column
i would argue that's more pure than even
what you would get from a his tag
but this is actually bona fide gcsf
identical to the amgen product
and so on on the right side you see the
sec that shows that it's monomer with
very little aggregate and then we did an
activity assay that showed
that the uh that the the material was
actually more active than the standard
that we bought
but going back to the 20 hours so any of
you who work in processing are like whoa
whoa we're not going to want to wait 20
hours especially room temperature
so what are you going to do about that
and that led to the other problem which
which we had
20 years ago variable unpredictable
cleaving rates
and so we we tried a whole bunch of
different proteins with this system
and what you see is that you know some
of them cleave faster or slower than
others so streptokinase cleaves pretty
well
but green fluorescent protein in panel b
in the same amount of time is maybe
60 or 50 percent cleaved and so that led
to
really the key breakthrough in all of
this and this was
a predictive model for anti-cleaving so
the question was
where is that variability coming from
and is there a way for us to
solve it and that's where the next sort
of
key experiment came along so in this
experiment what we did is we took
gcsf which we knew cleaved slow it took
20 hours to cleave
overnight now it turns out the first
five amino acids on gcsf
are mtplg so what we did is we took
those five amino acids
and we put them on the front end of
green fluorescent protein
and what you see in the graph is that
the green fluorescent protein then
behaves almost identically to gcsf
in terms of cleaving rate in a second
experiment we took streptokinase
which was known to cleave quite quickly
and very well behaved
it starts with mi agp
we put mi agp on the front of green
fluorescent protein
and sure enough the mi agp
then behaves exactly as streptokinase
and so the implication was
that the first five amino acids on the
front end of the target protein have
this profound influence on how the
target protein behaves
and in fact the target protein may not
matter at all and all these theories
that had been coming along for 20 years
about steric hindrance and the active
site and all kinds of other things
may actually not be relevant so what we
did is we
we took the native extine residues which
are cfn that's what normally follows
this intent in nature
and we put them on the front end of
enhanced green fluorescent protein
and then what we did is we varied the
first amino acid the cysteine to all of
the other 20 native amino acids
and what we found was that sure enough
that first amino acid has a huge
influence on the cleavage rate
so what you see in the y-axis is the
cleaving half-life in hours
where aromatic residues tyrosine
phenylalanine cleave very very slowly
whereas charged residues and small
residues alanine glycine asparagine
those tend to cleave much more slowly
and up to that point
we've been so yeah slower and faster up
to that point
we've been using methionine on the front
of pretty much all of our targets
because
most people when they think of
expressing a protein especially in e
coli
think of it as being methionine
um but it turns out that mt
which is the first two amino acids of
gcsf
they cleave slowly whereas mi
which are the first three amino acids of
streptokinase that cleaves much faster
and those cleavage behaviors the slower
for mt
the faster for mi is consistent with
what we
saw in the plus one amino acids so the
suggestion was
it might be that the first two or three
amino acids matter but they might matter
in a way that's consistent and sort of
additive to how
the amino acid behaves in the first
position so to test this hypothesis
what we did is we took our uh
the first the cfm we put it on the front
end of the
enhanced green fluorescent protein but
then we varied the first and second
position
relative to different families of amino
acids so if we did all 20 by 20 it would
be 400 clones
and we didn't have the resources for
that so we did a 6x6 and did 36 clones
and we came up with these data so each
one of these panels has the same first
amino acid and each line within the
panel
has the same second amino acid and i
often refer to this slide as sort of the
rosetta stone of why
intent research has been such a pain for
so long
what you see is that if you put an
aromatic of phenylalanine on the front
end pretty much everything behaves
really well
on the other hand if you put a proline
on the front end it abolishes cleaving
and you're done
but with methionine which was where most
of our work had been uh done
up to that point what you see is
the um the the cleaving rates are very
variable
and have a profound impact of the second
amino acid
and probably a little bit of the third
and so this explains why we were getting
all this highly variable cleavage rate
all of those years
and in fact if you look at the sort of
middle cleaving ones
a e and k that are sort of the middle
line cleaving a little bit slowly
what you see is e k and a a e and k
all cleave on the slower end of the
spectrum whereas if you look at the ones
at the bottom mmn and mfn that cleave
very very quickly and are basically done
at five hours
that m and that f are on the faster end
of the spectrum
and so the idea was that we could
predict
how fast a protein was going to cleave
based on its first two or three amino
acids
and more importantly if we knew what a
protein was going to cleave slowly we'd
be able to fix it we had ways of doing
it
and so with gcsf again it takes 20 hours
to cleave overnight
the wild type starts with mtp but now i
can look at the data that i have and say
hey you either want to change the first
or second amino acid to phenylalanine
and sure enough if you change the first
amino alanine to
from methionine to phenylalanine you
have ftp
and now you have a really well behaved
protein that cleaves quite quickly
and so this was actually the
breakthrough that made me think that
that we were ready to commercialize this
technology
and before you complain that if you
modify the front of the intent it's not
or the
target protein it's not native human
protein
this is a table that we threw together
pretty quickly where we have
released approved drugs and their trade
names
the actual n-terminus of the human
native protein
and the n-terminus of the drug substance
and the underlying amino acids are the
ones that have been
modified in order to make the drug
easier to manufacture
or expressible in e coli in the case of
gcsf
and along with that we have the proposed
changes that would allow these drugs to
change
to to um work with our intune and so the
point is that the pharmaceutical
industry has been changing the front end
of proteins for
since the beginning i mean gcsf goes
clear back to the beginning
in order to make them easier to um to
manufacture
and as a result we can use this in team
to make therapeutic proteins that are
perfectly consistent with drugs that
have already been approved many many
drugs that have already been approved
and so if we go back to this new
affinity capture resin
we have the ph sensitivity check with
our sensitivity enhancing domain
we have rapid cleaving with the
different mutations that we've
rationally introduced and what's really
nice is we now have reliable performance
we understand
why some in tunes cleave slower why some
in tunes cleave faster
and we know how to fix it and we know
how to predict it
and then finally i won't go into the
detail on all of these but we're looking
at
high binding capacities that we're
optimizing now
i think cheap is probably an optimistic
word
um it's not going to be cheap but it
will be in the same ballpark as a
protein a resin
or you know a fairly nice affinity resin
but it's also highly reusable we've
reused we've regenerated these resins
about 50 times now
without any loss of activity and the
regeneration protocol is just a mild
acid wash
it's nothing exotic and so
we've gone ahead and patent these we
have several issued patents now we have
some others pending
and um and we went ahead and created
this product and so the glossy brochure
the icap tag resin the customer makes
their their tag protein in their system
bind washy loot and regenerate the resin
and so what i wanted to do to kind of
wrap up was show you a few of the case
studies that we've done
this was a slide that came from the very
first run on the very first column that
we ever poured
and what we're doing is we're purifying
super folder gfp out of e coli
and what you see is the column itself in
the lower right
and the little green fluorescent protein
and the test tubes that came out
and a gel showing sort of the purity
that we got and again
first try with the first column that we
ever poured we got a nice yield nice
purity
and and we were very excited about this
result so we started trying some other
things one is we tried to
do streptokinase what you see is that we
have some protease problems so we get a
nice purity but there's definitely some
degradation bounds down below it
and uh it turns out that we looked into
this
and if you add protease inhibitors your
favorite
cocktail of protease inhibitors you can
actually clean up the protease problems
but what's cool is because the intent
actually
has a different mechanism than any of
the serine proteases that you're trying
to inhibit
the intent will still cleave perfectly
happily in the presence of protease
inhibitors
so moving on here's another example of
gcsf that we did from a later
optimization
again there's some bands that we need to
get rid of um
but my argument is if you put something
that pure into a polishing step you'd be
able to clean it up pretty quickly
um but then the exciting part comes so
in this case we're
purifying a single chain antibody from
xb293
so this is mammalian expression we're
able to get really nice secretion
into the cell culture supernatant and
again
uh in the aleutian bands i would argue
that you would be hard-pressed to find a
significant impurity
and the top is a is a silver stain gel
on the bottom is a western blood
and so we were able to show that we can
get good secretion we're using the serum
albumin leader sequence
but it seems to work quite well we can
get good expression of these proteins
um and then we went ahead and did mature
interferon from xb293 so again you don't
need the leader sequence because the
ending cleaves
off but the cool thing about this case
study even though we do have some
um we do have some degradation we got
good secretion
good expression good cleaving good
purity but what i like to point out is
that in this case
we were able actually to actually make
mature interferon with the true
native human and terminus um so that was
it's even more human than the
therapeutic protein based on interferon
that you can buy
and so again gcsf made in mammalian
cells another really nice purification
and then for the first time in this talk
we've actually managed to make ippo so
epigene
poetin expressed again in xv293
and again i would make the argument it
expresses well it goes into the
supernatant
it's completely bound in the flow
through and then after the cleavage
reaction
i would argue that that's a really
nicely purified glycoprotein
and i will have to admit that when we
strip the column that's what the cip is
clean in place
we see some aggregated epo a lot
frankly and we're still trying to figure
out how to optimize the buffer is to
minimize that
one of the nice things about this intune
is it seems only to care about ph
so it's impervious to pretty much any
other uh
things that you would add that won't
completely denature it altogether so
again a really nice purification
of a glycoprotein made in mammalian
cells and when we ran that through
a mass spec we found that the peak is a
nice sharp peak on mass spec
and it appears that it's the peak is
within the range that you would expect
for glycosylated epo
and so to wrap up uh this is the
non-protein a platform looking forward
um we believe that we can now put an
entine tag
on just about anything a lot of you are
going to say well i have a protein that
won't express won't fold won't stay
stable and is a total nightmare and i've
tried every tag in existence
this tag may not help you it's really
just to simplify the purification
the rule of thumb is that if you can
purify with a his tag you can probably
purify it with an inseam tag
that's been our experiment experience if
it's something that absolutely won't
behave
then the experience may be different but
but these therapeutic proteins most of
them are made solubly in either
mammalian cells or they're refolded in e
coli
we're working on protocols to re-fold
in teen tag proteins but we haven't run
into any successes or failures
uh yet and we're not that good at
refolding proteins to be perfectly
honest so if you're good at refolding
proteins we would love to work with you
on that
um but the idea is now you can in the
research
you can put a tag on you can purify
things quickly conveniently
high throughput but that same first
purification that you use to purify your
first candidate the first time
can now be scaled completely up into
clinical manufacturing
the same column the same process can be
used to make a drug that you can now
inject into humans because it'll be
fully native
with maybe one or two amino acid changes
at the front end
but it will not have anything resembling
a real tag on it
and so agile low capital investment and
readily platformable
and just to wrap up the protein the
company that we've started and i need to
put back in my my disclaimer since i'm
have ohio state all over this i have to
disclaim and let you know that i'm also
involved with the company
and so ohio state will not back me up on
anything that i've said here
um but but the company that we started
is called protein
proteincapturescience.com i know that
it's a mouthful but
try finding an unused url these days and
this one was actually still free
and we are hoping to launch this product
in the next two to three months um
may june probably at the latest and so
we're looking for people who want to try
it out
and we've budgeted for some free samples
don't ask us for a liter of resin
but if you want a five mil cartridge
like a high trap cartridge that can be
arranged
and we're going to have one mil
cartridges that we can definitely
arrange
and if your protein binds and cleaves
and you become interested in this
technology
then we're hoping that you'll become one
of our one of our first customers
and so if you go to protein capture
science we're still working on the web
page it's a little sketchy i agree
but by the time we launch it's going to
be fully developed but there is a sign
up if you want to go ahead and type in
your email address and write any
questions that you have they come
straight to me
and generally speaking i'm very
responsive and so i just wanted to wrap
up really quick by acknowledging my
group
um the big names on here everybody has
has helped in some way in different
pieces of what i showed you today
but the big one under collaborators and
co-inventors is chiang hwa
he was one of the ones who really
convinced me to look at split in teams
in the first place and he did a lot of
the early development work
and in my lab right now i have joe
terrace jacqueline miozzi
and brian marshall who are developing
the product itself and helping me get it
out the door
um before them michael coolbaugh he's
now at sanofi
uh su chang is at regeneron sam stimple
is
at i believe sanofi also ashwin is at
merck and yaman is at biogen and so
my students have done really really well
finding jobs and honestly
if you're interested in hiring a
top-notch phd or
undergrad you should also my students
are doing extremely well
um and i'm very proud of all of them
so that wraps up my talk and what i
wanted to do is thank you again for
coming
i hope that you're as excited about this
technology as i am i do think it has the
potential to make a significant
impact and i understand that
if you post questions they will be
emailed to me
and i can tell you that i will be very
responsive in answering them
so please email me if you want to set up
a conversation
i'm happy to talk by phone or we can
even set up a zoom meeting
as a professor i'm really really good at
that now
so that's all i'm going to say today and
uh thanks again for coming and i hope
that i will hear from you soon